but you still have like beefs I was
reading that you had some kind of
rivalry with Michael sweet who's a
singer all I know is that in the history
of headlines yeah on blabbermouth
yeah Bach slams [ __ ] sweet the greatest
headline all right that's a name I have
my sex tape what box slams [ __ ] sorry
nice [ __ ] good head yeah yeah say
that again box hey Dan
sweet slams [ __ ] sweet yeah what a cool
dad what a headline Dan tries to slam
[ __ ] okay yeah how are you still
getting into into rivalries with people
in music I don't get in I don't what if
I read something online yeah that has a
little check mark next to it so I know
it's the dude saying it mhm I figure you
can say it in person right right yeah if
I say some [ __ ] I expect people to say
what's up
all right Bon Jovi's dad as I didn't
threaten to kill you you know he's
waiting outside yeah that's true what
did Michael sweet to do I don't he threw
a Bible at me while I was wearing yellow
and black stripes he was a head-to-toe
[ __ ] amazing look why they do that
well cuz he believes in God he has a
clergy Anna band is melded into one use
Michael sweet exactly guys throwing
Bibles you better start praying Jesus
bro singer as far as I know yeah the
Bible throw Mikey Michael sweet no
that's the thing that's how he ends
every show with the [ __ ] witty
inversion a King James Version I didn't
understand was like what the whole fight
was about Michael sweet from striper
apparently said something online about
some cover of a Skid Row song and they
see said it was better than when
Sebastian did it I think I don't know
that's not why I that's not why I
slammed [ __ ] sweet why did you say
Blissey sweet because he goes plus he's
a tool to boot oh you're like [ __ ] yeah
I'm [ __ ] too long I'm gonna I'll show
you being a [ __ ] tools and how you
gonna call someone a toilet contest and
see who's a bigger [ __ ] tool but he's
got that little piece of hair under his
lip so bad so bad should anybody one
have a tool contest I will win
are you a bigger tool than most I've had
a lot of breath this guy's got a soul
patch it's part of my appeal that is the
tool badge of honor isn't it the soul
patch and when you're in a name when
you're in a band called striper you do
you wear stripe yes that's that's
exhausted that's the look though yeah
it's a good look it is a game yeah
you're jealous guys only diagonal you
were jealous because you didn't think to
wear stripes that's what this is about
that time that's kind of badass that
reminds me of the Lord like that makes
me feel all religious right and put you
in touch with Jesus this Montemayor I
feel better why they did you like that
why did he say you're a tool for what
Jesus told him it's a long story and I
really don't want to give them the time
did you just but you don't like each
other he put out a headline once saying
that he was asked to produce a Sebastian
Bach record who the [ __ ] do you think
asked that question could it be me what
I gotta say I never asked any guy in
strieber to produce my record you didn't
know no I never did this is the way it
is right sorry